to find the origin of malthus the
malefic demon from hell's deepest
crevices we must look back to the
ancient text that first detailed the
infernal entity's name
the devil's welcome one page studied by
mia form and annabelle tells of the
right of evocation
or the ceremony of calling upon an evil
spirit demon or deity it says there is a
fragment of the dead sea scrolls
entitled curses of belial which tells of
the existence of demons the dead sea
scrolls are ancient jewish manuscripts
found in the qumran caves and the dead
sea's western bank so this book is
suggesting that there is actually
a long-lost piece called curses of
belial reflecting the sentiments shared
by demons to prey on weak souls
belial is a real term referenced in
several religious texts which some
religions have personified as the devil
so when mia reads about how belial was
thought to have influenced sin
through the way that people addressed
him and all his guilty lot she's
essentially learning that the other
demons mentioned in this fragment
including valik malthus and others
all answered to belial the dead sea
scrolls were discovered in 1947 and
thought to be 1800 to 2000 years old
making them the oldest copies of
biblical text ever discovered if we take
those dates and apply them to the
conjuring universe we can estimate that
the earliest recorded text about malthus
was written around
20 bce we'll probably never know the
actual creation date of the demon
because this is as far as its lore goes
back
but that's good enough for me to put a
date in the thumbnail to learn about
the entire history of the presence that
made this creepy children's toy famous
including how it may become the most
powerful being in the conjuring universe
stick around
to the end of this video
welcome to horror history my name is
professor sisi's world what do they call
me
a youtuber an influencer a creator
something inhuman
something like that today's lesson is
malthus who most notably is the
antagonist of the annabelle spin-offs
like many conjuring villains malthus is
based on mythological folklore
the lesser key of solomon is a 17th
century spell book on demonology that
contains details about many of the
demons found in popular fiction
including paimon from hereditary and
valik from the conjuring too
it's divided up into five titles ours
goetsia focuses on the practice of
conjuring demons
so naturally it serves as a major source
of lore for the conjuring franchise they
contain 72 demons each one
serving some kind of role in the
hierarchy of hell there are kings
dukes princes marquises knights
presidents and earls malthus is
considered an earl of hell
also sometimes known as halfus this
demon is not associated with the ram
form as portrayed in the movies but
rather as a wicked stork with a hoarse
voice i just imagine malthus having the
voice of jeff garlin
alphys is known for building up towns to
house weapons and ammunition for his 26
legions of warrior demons which he can
send to attack wherever he pleases
we see this concept realized in a
different way in annabelle where malthus
is the subject of evocation for not an
army but a cult known as the disciples
of iran
let's get into the demon's early
interactions with mankind
for as long as there have been religious
entities those entities have had
followers malthus followers are a cult
known as the disciples of ram
a reference to the rarely seen true form
of the creature a humanoid figure with
ram-like horns it also possesses long
claw-like fingers and charcoal black
features which are explained by
annabelle director john leonetti
i wanted it to be like this thing had
been in hell and it was jet
black like charred like he's really been
in hell and that was kind of the visual
kind of inspiration for him he's also
got a beautiful goatee
that one gets the cz stamp of approval
malthus is your traditional gargoyle
looking demon which works thematically
to tie the character into this idea of a
religious clash
which takes me back to his milieu the
evocation page the page that explains
the summoning of the demon mentions that
an incantation is to be performed with
spilled blood we can't see the entire
text but it looks like the summoner
should be both impious
and uncleanly looking at the two
disciples of ram who performed the
ritual on annabelle i'd say they check
those boxes pretty neatly
especially the uncleanly part let's move
ahead to the chapter
specifically about malthus and his
disciples of iran the passage lays out
the rules
in layman's terms in order for malthus
to take a soul and possess a body
the victim must agree to give it up once
the deal is made it's everlasting and
the church fears this because if the
demon tricks someone into doing this
there's not really much they can do to
fix it
which brings us to the three stages of
demonic activity
infestation oppression and possession
why don't i have a projector screen like
that that explains the first stage
infestation that's the whispering the
footsteps the feeling
of another presence which ultimately
grows into oppression the second stage
this is definitely the case for malthus
whose targets include an orphan who is
treated differently by the other girls
for her disability a new mother who
spends her days alone due to her
husband's busy work schedule a nurse who
can't say no to helping people and a
student who is desperate to make contact
with her deceased
father breaks the victim down crushes
their will
and once in a weakened state leads them
to the third and final stage
possession the devil's welcome also
explains a couple more rules
as i mentioned blood must be shed to
summon him but this is only to be done
as a sacrifice to malthus whatever
creature is sacrificed is not to be used
for food unless it's meat given to them
by the demon
specifically for food the last paragraph
on the page says and the bow shall be in
the earth and i will establish my
covenant unto thee which i have made
between me and thee
for every living creature of all flesh
that shall be upon this earth so he's
saying that he wants to take all the
souls and possess
every living creature on the planet so
basically the same thing that the music
industry is trying to do
there's a graphic on the right labeled
malthus earl of hell the only time the
protagonist is ever mentioned by name in
the series and the picture shows the ram
demon grabbing this baby which
represents a common tactic he's known to
use by putting a baby in danger he can
sometimes pressure a naive mother into
offering her soul in exchange for the
child's safety
but she said that it can't take leah you
said that it has to be offered
that a baby cannot offer its soul
oh my god this wouldn't be the only
clever tactic of deception used by the
demon
the devil is the father of lies demons
are his manipulators no one ever plans
to offer their soul
this presence would infest many homes
over the years and each of them taught
the fiend some new tricks that it would
carry on to its next target
meaning if it isn't contained it could
become more and more deceptive making it
more and more powerful we will pick up
on some of these tricks as we follow
malthus's journey through history
malthus's earliest known targets were
the mullens family samuel and esther
they lost their seven-year-old daughter
annabelle b
mullens to a car accident in 1943. so
malthus tried to manipulate them as they
were mourning the young girl's diary was
abruptly cut short but after many nights
a new message appeared
dear diary today i came home annabelle
comes home
rated r not yet annabelle comes home
we're still on annabelle creation
it all started one night during dinner
when they heard b's favorite record
start playing randomly and assumed it
was her spirits they noticed more and
more activity that mimicked the things
that their daughter used to do
and eventually they found a note asking
for their permission to move into this
doll so that she could be with them
forever and they happily agreed
this was not the spirit of their
deceased daughter however and by falling
for this trick and having faith that
they could speak to be again the evil
entity
got stronger soon it could use the form
of the mullins girl
they were able to see what they thought
was her ghost in fleeting glimpses
this was stage 1 infestation
but we soon realized it wasn't our nfl
at all
demons what what do they want
a soul and they won't stop until they
get one
mrs mullins decided to approach one of
the apparitions with a cross but what
appeared to be her daughter convulsed
and twisted itself
into a demonic form she dropped the
cross in shock and malthus attacked her
scarring her face and taking out her
left eye
as the girl's mother mrs mullins was the
most psychologically vulnerable this was
stage two
oppression it had used her hope of
speaking to her daughter again to make
an attempt at her soul
samuel reached out to the church and
they saved mrs mullins from potentially
being possessed but the evil was still
attached to the doll so it was locked
away in bee's closet and surrounded by
bible pages
a cross and doused with holy water the
demonic entity would cease but the
mullins did not realize the room would
have to continuously be blessed in order
for the seal to remain strong
four years later in 1947 the dead sea
scroll is discovered and word of the
disciples of ram would soon spread into
the troubled group of people that would
start the cult another eight years go by
and mr mullins and his wife decided to
take on a group of girls from saint
eustace's orphanage they believed that
sheltering these girls would be their
penance but they unknowingly gave
malthus exactly what it wanted a new
weaker target whose soul was ripe for
possession it's been quiet
for 12 years the strange activity would
begin again
after the girls moved in in 1955 the new
target is janus a young girl who is
partially immobilized by polio
after discovering her malthus uses the
form of b to sneak up on her and give
her a fright at dinner the first night
the lights flicker a sign that the evil
is no longer contained to that single
closet
that night it leaves janice a note
reading find me referencing a game that
bee used to play with her father
janus is led into bee's room which is
supposed to be locked malthus has left
the key to the closet for her to find
and discover the hiding place of the
doll it makes her uncomfortable
so she covers it up and attempts to lock
it away but when her back is turned the
inhuman spirit appears behind her but
when the sheet is removed malthus is in
a form and not visible to the human eye
more scary stuff begins to happen around
the house linda sees the doll move on
its own while playing hide and seek and
a mask wearing form resembling mrs
mullen scares the girls
disappearing as the light is turned on
that wasn't a ghost
ghost can only be of dead people one
night janice is lured back into bee's
room where she catches an apparition
asking her for help
can you help me what do you need
your soul malthus proceeds to drag her
around leaving a laceration on her leg
she manages to escape the room but
malthus slams all of the bedroom doors
so that she can't get help
leaving her no option but to go for the
stair lift isolating the target to make
her feel alone seems to be a common
tactic for malthus she looks up and sees
the evil exiting the room in what
appears to be a gaseous form
this is the only time we see the demon
travel like this but i can only assume
that this is how it usually gets around
to be able to travel through walls and
perhaps change itself into multiple
forms
janet's chair stalls three-fourths of
the way down so she tries to get up and
crawl to safety on her own
the last thing she sees is the form of b
standing at the top of the stairs before
she is irrigated high into the foyer and
then dropped onto the cold
hard floor she later admits to sister
charlotte who is in charge of all the
orphans that she believes that the
presence is preying on her because she
is the weakest but charlotte disagrees
telling her that the devil preys on
those weak of faith
not weak of flesh or bone the night she
returns from the hospital her friend
linda has a few scary experiences with
malthus she looks through the keyhole to
bee's room and sees the animal doll
using the rocking chair but when she
opens the door
it's nowhere to be seen then as she's
playing with the ball shooter in her
room the invisible entity grabs it and
raises it to the top of the door frame
before yanking it from her hands she
hears loud footsteps or perhaps hoof
steps running towards her so she hides
in her top bunk and listens as the
lights are turned off and malthus
inhabits the lower bunk leaving behind
charred black footsteps another sign of
the burning the creature would have
endured in the deepest layers of hell
linda looks down and sees annabelle
staring back up at her
and she hides under the covers after
seeing malthus in its true demonic form
at this point janus linda and the two
older girls carol and nancy have all had
scary experiences with malthus but it is
not yet attempted to possess
any of them i think the demon is testing
each of the girls to see whose faith is
the weakest
janice is the weakest of body but it's
also possible that this also led to her
faith being weakened as she becomes
older and more crippled she realizes
that no family will want to take in a
broken child and that idea is
demoralizing for her she's also dealing
with the fact that she's treated
differently than the other girls due to
her condition
and this makes her an easy target
because the demonic attacks can be
explained away as janice lashing out as
a response to what she's going through
emotionally she's at that age where her
hormones take over her emotions an
age that is commonly associated with
attracting a poltergeist because the
spirits are said to be attracted to the
negative feelings that come with nearing
those teenage years
the next day sister charlotte takes her
out into the sunlight and malthus makes
up its mind about who to try to possess
furs it takes the form of a nun
something we've seen many times from its
european counterpart valik the creepy
nun is a popular form for these demons
to take because it represents an attack
on the victim's religious belief
much like how the ominous knocking and
the conjuring always comes in threes as
an insult to the holy trinity the creepy
nun shoves janets out of the wheelchair
and into the barn
where it reverts to the form of bee to
crawl out of the shadows and begin a
stage three
possession in the controversy you
basically just have to puke in someone's
mouth to possess them
i guess i think malthus essentially just
made janice give up at this point she
had gotten back from the hospital and
already she was going to have another
demonic encounter and probably another
injury
with one victim possessed malthus had
achieved its goal but remember the text
in the devil's welcome to establish
covenants unto the people and for every
living creature of
all flesh that shall be upon the earth
in other words malthus will now use
janus to try to possess the bodies of
the others then keep expanding out until
the whole world is taken over
for its next target malthus wants to
take advantage of the element of
surprise so when sister charlotte comes
in to check on her janice pretends to be
fine but with the added power of janus
the ram demon decides to try again with
a target that it was unable to possess
13 years ago
[Music]
mr mullins is alerted to the return of
the annabelle doll from linda and goes
inside to find it ready to face him in
his kitchen but the doll is not actually
possessed by malthus the demon only
moves it around to give the appearance
of possession
as explained later on by lorraine warren
demonic spirits don't possess things
they possess people janice does her best
lights out diana impression and
transforms into
its traditional gargoyle or ram demon
form which i'll be referring to as its
true form because that's what i picture
in my head
when i think about a demon this time
even holding up a cross
is not enough to protect him from the
evil i think it's a combination of
malthus gaining power
and by possessing janus and the fact
that his cross is homemade and he admits
that it isn't his best work
malthus brutally breaks off each of his
fingers one by one forcing him to drop
the cross before moving in on him
even if mr mullins supposedly wasn't
using his best cross it still speaks
volumes to the power of malthus we never
see any of the other conjuring villains
do anything like this
this scene represents the power of
belief it's a common trope for religious
people to claim they found religion
after a personal tragedy for mr mullins
losing his daughter created the negative
energy that initially attracted malthus
so the idea of turning to religion is
used in a literal sense where bible
pages and holy water are used to seal
the demon away
so now the movie is showing us that
letting go of religion literally
dropping the cross
has opened him back up to being
vulnerable to malthus linda realizes
that the evil presence seems to be
connected to the creepy doll and tries
to discard it in the well
look linda just because it works for
coraline doesn't mean it's gonna work
for you
she once again hears hooves march up
behind her the closer she gets to the
well
after dropping it in she hears a small
voice call out help me
it's hard to tell for sure but this
seems to be bee's voice so this is
probably malthus once again
trying to mislead her by making her
think that bee's soul is trapped in the
doll or something
it nearly works because linda is
practically dragged into the well by a
pale pair of hands with long fingers
this doesn't appear to be b
or janus it could be the hands of the
nun form that i mentioned earlier or
it's possible that there were other
forms acquired before being with the
help of sister charlotte linda is saved
and the well is covered but when they
return to the house the annabelle doll
is back on the couch where janice had
just been sleeping
charlotte takes the doll into mrs
mullen's room looking for answers and
her reaction speaks to the terror that
it brought her 12 years ago
no no get that thing away from me she
claims that the evil has returned
calling it the devil itself which is
probably not accurate based on what we
know from the devil's welcome malthus is
just one of the many demons working
under the devil belial with the demonic
nature of the haunting now revealed
malthus can no longer rely on deception
to possess its victims so with its game
plan out the window it launches a
full-on offensive attack
at this point we have multiple things
going on in multiple locations i would
still attribute all of this activity to
malthus but because
janus is still alive and possessed by
malthus she's essentially programmed to
act on its behalf
so janus can be upstairs terrorizing the
orphans while malthus is downstairs
using whatever form it wants to to
torment mrs mullins
so nancy carroll and tierney find janus
having tea with the annabelle doll and a
janus attacks nancy
sister charlotte attempts to dispel the
demon using prayer so janus aeriates her
into a mirror the girls try to scream
for help but janice has another idea
meanwhile malthus cuts mrs mullins in
half crucifies her to a wall and
rings her bell to try to lure the girls
into the room they're horrified by what
they find
and they try to flee the property using
mr mullen's truck where they encounter a
scarecrow with an ability to move on its
own
using the rules about these demons that
we've already established we can guess
that it's another one of malthus's
tricks
just like with the annabelle doll the
scarecrow is not possessed but simply
moved around to give the impression of
possession
the girls try to hide in the barn but
carol gets locked in alone where she
encounters the scarecrow
again it's in a position reminiscent of
a crucifix and again it ties back into
malthus making a mockery of religious
symbols she discovers the demonic true
form hiding inside the scarecrow and it
busts out
climbs to the ceiling and descends upon
her but she's able to get away to the
toy shop where nancy finds her
in the house linda discovers the remains
of mrs mullins which jolt to life and
come after her so she hides in the dumb
waiter which janus is able to crawl
through to come after her she sees the
claw of malthus's true form grasp onto
the platform meaning that both the
possessed janus and the demon itself are
coming after her
she hides in the blessed closet where
annabelle had once been sealed by the
priest but janice finds her sister
charlotte is able to rescue her once
again by throwing her cross necklace
around janus and locking her into the
closet
i think it's quite fitting that malthus
is continually foiled by an actual nun
the pain caused by these religious items
causes malthus to go crazy causing the
house to shake
lights to flicker electronics to glitch
furniture to fly all around in glass to
shatter the demonic growl can even be
heard from outside the house as malthus
despite the pain that this might have
caused penetrates the bible page plaster
wall allowing janus to disappear into
the night
only the annabelle doll and sister
charlotte's necklace are left behind
it appears that malthus maybe stays with
the doll though because after father
massey blesses the house the doll is
sent away with the police the father
claims that the evil is gone and that
the doll is now just a doll but after
being moved to a new bible page-lined
room
annabelle is still under the control of
an external force
it seems that malthus stayed with the
doll by choice it's later described by
paranormal expert ed warren who explains
that the demonic force is latched on to
the doll
of course it's never explicitly
explained why but i would guess it's for
one of two reasons perhaps malthus saw
value in remaining with the annabelle
doll because it had proven itself
successful as a way to trick people
or maybe there's actually some kind of
bond being formed between the evil deity
and this handmade toy
in the same way that ed warren describes
the items in his cursed artifact room
well why not just throw him in an
incinerator
destroy him but i would only destroy the
vessel
sometimes it's better to keep the genie
in the bottle janice somehow ends up at
st
joakim orphanage where she's adopted by
a couple named mr and mrs higgins she
takes on the name annabelle the actual
first name of b although she is still
possessed she doesn't immediately take
on an evil persona
instead becoming more and more horrible
over the next couple years before
eventually running away from home to
join a cult
of course the cults she joins is the
disciples of ram the charles manson-led
group dedicated to summoning malthus she
gets a crazy looking cult as boyfriend
and although this part of the story
isn't shown on screen
i'm guessing it's no coincidence that
the annabelle doll ends up in the hands
of mr and mrs higgins next door neighbor
mia form
perhaps it was one of the cult's
evocation spells that caused the doll to
be moved so close to home
on october 2nd 1967 12 years after her
adoption into the higgins family and
roughly a decade after she ran away
janus now known as annabelle would come
home annabelle comes home
rated r nope it's still not you
[Music]
as part of her ritual to call upon
malves janice and her boyfriend invade
her adoptive parents home
one evening and slit their throats
before heading next door to steal back
the doll
this fulfills the blood sacrifice
requirements of the evocation spell part
of the ritual to reawaken the demon
also seems to involve janus offering
herself while holding the doll in her
arms and possibly leaving this a symbol
on the wall in red paints or maybe she
just felt that was an improvements to
the wallpaper of the nursery i mean i
kind of like it the summoning ritual
seems to do the trick
because the next day unexplainable
occurrences start happening in john and
mia's house
including a sewing machine turning on in
the middle of the night the doll moving
on its own and the day after that
unprovoked movement of a rocking chair
mia tells her husband that she can't
bear to have the doll anymore
the doll would get rid of it she had it
in her hands
but like the time that linda tried to
dump the doll down the well it somehow
appears again
it seems that if malthus has its targets
set on you there's nothing you can
actually do to get rid of the annabelle
doll
unlike the penguin from mario 64.
on october 5th malthus starts a fire in
the form's kitchen and when a pregnant
mia tries to get away
she is aerated back into the flames
thinking the house is haunted or
something jon and mia move to pasadena
after mio delivers the baby
this is one of the classic horror movie
blunders malthus simply follows them
there and continues to mess with them by
screwing with the tv and using the
appearance of the child and teenage
janus to scare mia and get inside her
head or at least
something that looks like janus i mean
malthus is a pretty important demon who
i'm sure can't be bothered by little
trivial details like what janus actually
looks like
i also talked earlier about how malthus
was able to exploit the negative
emotions of the mullens when they were
in mourning it uses similar tactics here
by listening in on john and mia's
conversations about the stress caused by
their new parenthood and
jon's job to divide them even further
malthus seems to focus its attacks on
when mia is home alone with the baby to
make her feel further isolated like on
october 7th when it lures her into the
living room while hiding behind the
curtain a little trick it picked up from
being then blasting her to the ground
and running away in the form of janus
or whatever with mia malthus is taking a
somewhat similar approach as it did with
the mullins instead of tricking them
into giving up their souls with the
false promise of speaking to their
daughter again malthus is pretending to
go after the soul of the baby in hopes
that mia will offer her soul in exchange
for her child's safety
demons can't just take sort mere soul
needs to be offered to the demon before
it can take it
and a baby cannot offer its soul
so the next night malthus does
everything it can to make mia feel that
her baby is in danger
after putting leah to bed she goes to
the basement to put some stuff into
storage when she hears the sound of a
baby fussing and a carriage appears at
the end of the room
she investigates to find that the
stroller is actually empty and
that this is a trap devised by malthus
in its true form
malthus grabs her forearm and scratches
the a symbol onto it
the creature rises up to a terrifying
height as she runs away and the elevator
won't operate when she tries to ride it
to safety forcing her to run back
through the basements to get to the
stairs
she hears her baby crying as she runs
out a virtual suicide squeeze back to
her apartment but trips and drops her
flashlight when she looks back
over the edge she realizes that malthus
is right below her
almost the same scenario as when linda
saw malthus in the bunk below her at the
mullen's farmhouse
when she gets back to her floor she
looks back and sees malthus growling and
staring at her from less than one full
flight of stairs below
then during one lightning strike it is
instantly advanced up to her level
before she sprints the rest of the way
into her apartments this is one of the
only times we actually see malthus use
this method of extremely fast movement
or possibly teleportation but it does
help explain something about annabelle
creation
specifically the part where it scares
the girls out of the downstairs bedroom
then is already waiting for them when
they run to the barn
some unspecified amount of time goes by
it's long enough that the scratch on
mia's arm is fully healed on the way
home from a bookstore she hears janice
annabelle whisper her name and the baby
stroller rolls into the street and gets
the old gaged creed treatment from a
garbage truck luckily for her
leah wasn't in the stroller but this is
all part of malthus's plan to make her
feel like giving up her soul is the only
way to save her baby
it continues this narrative later when
it traps mia in the nursery and bombards
the baby with a barrage of heavy books
off the bookshelf
mia is able to break out of the room and
get to her daughter so malthus terrifies
her by lifting up the annabelle doll
while staring at her from the shadows
with bloodshot eyes a terrified john and
mia send the doll away with their priest
father perez
so malthus goes along for the ride
lending more credence to my theory that
there's some kind of binding force
between the demon and the doll
on the drive malthus interrupts the
father's baseball game by messing with
the radio
rude just rude the father tries to bring
the doll into the church and mouth us
perhaps remembering the pain inflicted
by
being locked away and surrounded by holy
items channels a ton of power and
aeriates father perez into the street
janus or at least malthus in its janus
form takes the doll back to return it to
mia when jon discovers what happened to
father perez he tries to call and warn
his wife but malthus messes with the
phone lines
it's interesting to me that a demon that
existed long before electronic
technology does so much tampering with
phones tvs and radios but it would make
sense that it would try to deceive
humans by using their primary methods of
communication just as it used a nun form
before taking the soul of janus it now
uses the form of father perez to stage
its final attack on her
my god has mercy on your soul
it pulls out all the stops to try to
convince mia to offer her soul like
playing demonic chanting over the record
player disfiguring the dolls in the
nursery
crawling on the ceiling and even
kidnapping leo which sends mia into a
desperate search for her daughter that
culminates in her asking
and her getting her answer written on
the ceiling before getting the revised
answer written on the opening window
it's a suggestion to mia to give her
life so that malthus can harvest her
soul but at the end of the day she must
be the one to give herself up
john arrives just in time to save mia
from throwing her life away however
malthus still ends up getting what it
wanted in the end when their friend
evelyn gives her own soul in mia's dead
so malthus does win this round but the
form family gets their baby back and the
annabelle doll disappears from their
lives
in april of 1968 the doll somehow ended
up in a gift shop where a woman who
claimed to have been looking everywhere
for one of mr mullin's limited edition
dolls picked it up and gave it to her
daughter camilla as a birthday present
like with each of the previous victims
camilla and her roommate debbie start to
notice small paranormal occurrences that
ramp up over the months that would
follow
at first they would just notice the
doll's hand or leg move then it would
move from room to room when they were
gone
they hired a medium who seemed to
successfully make contact with the
spirit of annabel higgins not realizing
that she was actually talking to malthus
malthus told the medium that annabelle
passed away in their apartment long ago
and wanted permission to move into the
doll and be friends with the nurses that
live there
as we know by now this was all a trick
they began to find unsettling notes
which lead up to malthus vandalizing
their spare room they try throwing the
doll into the dumpster but as we know
that doesn't work either debbie finds
another ominous note and they discover
the annabelle doll sitting back in the
apartment once more
something also happens between the doll
and one of their boyfriends though it's
not clear exactly what
realizing they're in more trouble than
the medium led them to believe they
decided to call in the big hell
and contact renowned demonologist ed and
lorraine warren the warrens explained
how the inhuman spirits tricked them
you gave it permission to infest your
lives before things get any worse ed and
lorraine called the church to have a
priest sent in to bless the apartment
and its inhabitants which seems to do
the trick
i think malthus knew what it was up
against here and decided to calm down
for the time being
the warrens would take the doll with
them for safe keeping annabelle was
finally
coming home annabelle comes home
as ed and lorraine head back home after
finally securing the annabelle doll
their car breaks down next to a cemetery
in maryville given malthus's tendency to
mess with lights tvs
radios telephones record players
elevators and chairlifts i'm sure this
breakdown was probably a result of the
evil entity associated with the doll
malthus decided to do this next to a
cemetery because of another powerful
attribute
this demon possesses it's the doll head
it's a beacon for other spirits so all
of the lingering spirits from the
graveyard are drawn to mount this who is
latched onto the doll and malthus is
able to manipulate these spirits into
doing its bidding
one of them pushes ed into the street in
front of a speeding truck judd crandall
would not have been pleased
malthus takes over the truck so that the
driver has no control and tries to take
out ed who is barely able to dodge the
oncoming vehicle the inhuman spirit was
far more powerful than they anticipated
their priest father gordon is waiting
for them when they arrive home
as they take annabelle to the artifact
room the doll stares at their young
daughter judy perhaps perceiving her
as a weaker target at first they leave
the doll in a rocking chair but it
causes complete chaos making clocks run
backwards and influencing other
artifacts to come to life
a simple blessing and splash of holy
water is not enough to contain it so
they build a glass case using material
from the trinity church chapel the doll
gains a reputation as the warren's most
malevolent item
at least at the time it would continue
to be housed at their home in monroe
connecticut and be blessed twice a month
by a priest
it would remain there for the next three
years in 1971 while the warrens are
investigating a case in rhode island
they bring back the spirit of a witch
named bathsheba because bathsheba is
particularly malicious and because
malthus is a beacon for other spirits
the witch becomes attracted to the doll
and frees it from the protective casing
in the middle of the nights bathsheba
takes the doll out into one of the rooms
judy is woken up by bathsheba pulling at
her ankle and investigates the house she
finds bathsheba rocking on a chair and
combing annabelle's hair in one of the
rooms
malthus turns annabelle's head to give
the appearance that the doll itself is
turning to stare at judy she tries to
exit the room but finds that she's
locked in
and the two malevolent spirits have
disappeared from human sight this is a
potentially disastrous situation
you have one inexperienced young medium
trapped inside with two
powerful and malicious supernatural
entities one of them starts hurling
furniture at her but luckily ed and
lorraine get home in time to rescue her
before she takes on any damage
edit checks the cursed artifact room to
see if anything is out of order
but by that time annabelle is back in
the glass case so this potential
catastrophe ends up being more of a
minor incident but perhaps this also
reinvigorated the demon spirits the
following year in september 1972 shortly
before judy warren's birthday party that
year a girl named daniela rios sneaks
into the warren's artifact room and
places a photo of her deceased father on
the piano hoping to find a way to make
contact with the other side to talk to
him
malthus senses that she's a vulnerable
target because she's in mourning just
like mr and mrs mullins were
she asked for a sign from any presents
that might be in the room so malthus
leans the annabelle doll forward against
the glass this causes daniella to open
up the case and pick up the doll but
just then a smoke alarm from the kitchen
sends her quickly on her way however she
forgets to lock the case back up and
annabelle is finally able to escape
again
as a beacon for other spirits malthus is
able to release many more horrifying
entities from the objects that they're
bound to
a few of them include the fairy man the
black shuck the haunted wedding dress of
anna baker and others
after escaping its prison the annabelle
doll sits at the kitchen table as judy's
babysitter mary ellen orders a pizza
the doorbell rings accompanied by a
familiar set of three knocks when mary
ellen looks through the peephole no one
is there but when she opens the door she
sees b
who asks if annabelle can come to play
when mary ellen says she has the wrong
house she tells her to look right behind
her but the doll is now gone
malthus takes on different forms for
different people to try to deceive them
in daniela's case it uses the form of
her father which is part of malthus's
plan to lull her into a sense of
security
later on judy senses something going on
upstairs and sees the bride associated
with the haunted wedding dress go into
one of the rooms however this can't just
be the ghost on its own because it finds
a note that says
miss me just like the nurses did when
malthus began terrorizing them
so when the bride comes at her with a
knife it's likely being driven by
malthus later that night malthus
continues to haunt judy by hiding the
remote under the couch and frightening
her with the annabelle doll when she
goes to look for it
the black chuck is a werewolf-like
creature that guards the perimeter of
the house preventing mary ellen's love
interest bob from offering help to the
three girls daniella is lured into the
cursed artifact room again when malthus
leaves the door unlocked to tempt her
she tries using the morning bracelets an
item said to let somebody connect with a
deceased loved one while this bracelet
does work for lorraine
under the right circumstances malthus
interferes with it by pretending to be
her dad
she sees his face appear in the mirror
but when she turns to look at him one of
his eyes is missing much like mrs
mullins
malthus probably saw how much the
one-eyed mrs mullen scared the girls
back at the farmhouse and decided to try
to use it again on daniella that's
probably what makes malthus one of the
cleverest and most dangerous inhuman
spirits in the conjuring franchise it
never forgets an old trick so the longer
it sticks around the more tactics it
learns and the better it gets at
deceiving its prey and coercing them to
give up their souls
the fact that it still uses b mullens as
one of its forms 29 years after her
death
just proves that malthus always still
has an old trick at its disposal
as with the mullins and the form
residence hauntings before malthus wraps
things up throughout the nights to try
to put its victims on
edge first it shatters mary ellen's milk
class then randomly turns on the radio
when she checks in on her sleeping judy
mary ellen discovers the annabelle doll
under the covers she finds it kind of
disturbing but doesn't know that the
doll is attached to an evil entity so
she doesn't think much of it when she
goes back downstairs the tv is on
malthus also messes with the tv inside
the artifact room where daniela is
this time instead of pulling out another
old trick it puts a new one
on display by making the television show
what happens a few seconds into the
future
like many of the strange things that
happen in the controvers this phenomenon
isn't ever explained but i personally
think that it's actually very simple
if lorraine has a clairvoyant ability
which allows her to foresee future
events like her daughter being in danger
in the conjuring one and her husband
being in danger in the conjuring too
who's to say that malthus doesn't also
have a touch of clairvoyance and since
we've already seen that malthus has the
ability to make electronics go haywire
it doesn't seem like too much of a
stretch for it to be able to display
these future events on a tv screen
meanwhile mary ellen hears a tape player
playing audio of ed and lorraine's case
file on their investigation of the fairy
man
an evil spirit set loose by malthus she
finds the source of the audio and turns
it off the fairy man is known for
putting coins over the eyes of its
victims and she follows a trail of coins
until she sees a pair of them floating
on the ceiling
we saw malthus hide on the ceiling
before attacking carol in 1955 and
evelyn in 1967. so seeing the fairy man
use this approach means that malthus was
probably involved it's likely using the
fairy man as a conduit in the same way
we saw valik use the ghost of bill
wilkins in the conjuring too
mary ellen runs for it but she trips on
something gets aerated back into the
dark
using your flashlight she's able to
temporarily free herself from the evil
spirit's grip
she immediately hightails it to judy's
room but judy would have her own
confrontation in which malthus would
bring out its full
arsenal of alternate forms
judy sleeps next to a revolving color
wheel lamp a novelty item that dates
back to the 1950s this lamp would have
an unusual effect on the demon malthus
it begins with malthus dragging judy by
the ankle to wake her up
this is exactly how bathsheba woke up
her victims in the conjuring though it's
not clear if bathsheba actually escaped
the music box it was captured in or if
malthus just learned this from the
witch's ghost when they met the previous
year when she wakes up
judy quickly realizes that something is
wrong when she discovers the annabelle
doll underneath the covers with her
b appears from under the covers at the
foot of the bed and scares her causing
her to knock over the color wheel it
continues to spin and projects its
colored light onto the wall as each
color changes a different form of
malthus is displayed
it starts with the doll then b then the
adult version of janus and finally the
rarely seen true form of malthus then it
appears behind her on the bed and
screeches at her she bolts out of the
room where mary ellen is waiting for her
with the black chuck outside they
realize they're trapped in they place a
call to lorraine for help but malthus
has manipulated the phone lines as well
can i speak to annabelle i'm sorry
you need to give her a soul dear
what a soul she wants her soul
give me her soul that's even more
annoying than telemarketers
well no maybe not that annoying before
trying to make an attempt on one of
their souls all of the bells in the
house start ringing which might be
another callback to mrs mullins who had
a bedside hand belt to request hell
then the typewriter goes all jack
torrance and writes the words miss me
over and over a phone starts ringing in
the artifact room and
judy and mary ellen get in there just in
time to stop daniella from touching it
she admits to being the one who let
annabelle out of the case and has bad
news regarding the other spirits in the
room
what else did you touch everything
this sends mary ellen into an asthma
attack but as judy goes to fetch her
inhaler the creepy bride sneaks up on
daniella using the same teleport forward
mechanic that malthus used on mia form
in the stairwell
it appears that she's stabbed daniela in
the stomach but it's only an illusion
she pins her to the ground and pukes
inside her mouth
so for the first time since janus in
1955 malthus has a new vessel
after judy safely returns with the
inhaler daniella tries to beckon the two
of them to go upstairs but judy
taking after her mother's medium
abilities senses something is wrong
and leads mary ellen to try to find the
annabelle doll so they can put an end to
the horror they were living through that
night
they find the cursed children's toy in
the closet inside the warren's office
but the door is locked
so they have to play this board game
feely mealy in order to win the key
i found it a bit strange that this evil
inhuman spirit would just stop in the
middle of everything and strike up a
board game with these kids but when i
went back i realized
that the game is seen in the room of
cursed objects at the beginning so this
is probably another trial where malthus
is manipulating whatever evil spirit was
living in this board game judy is able
to win the key and mary ellen ventures
into the closet which now resembles the
fairy man's tombs she's only able to
toss the doll back to judy before being
pulled back into the abyss but judy
recovers the fumble and makes a break
for the end zone before being met with
daniela who is infused with both the
evil of malthus and the ire of the
wedding dress spirit
mary ellen comes in with the key block
and big brain judy's fast thinking
probably saves a couple of lives when
she turns on a projector with a
recording of ed
performing an exorcism this essentially
seems to have the same effect as him
performing the actual exorcism and
causes immense pain to the demonic
presence inside of her
this buys them just enough time to get
annabelle back to the case but when judy
opens it malthus slams it shut
corners her and attempts to suck out
judy's soul using a dementor's kiss
as you may know the dementor's kiss is
an act performed by the wraith-like
species of prison guards in the
wizarding world aka the harry potter
franchise to suck out the soul of anyone
who gets in their way the controvers in
the wizarding world may both be warner
brothers properties but they're not the
same universe however malthus doesn't
seem to care and he nearly performs the
dementor's kiss on judy mary ellen tries
to come in and save her so malthus gets
in one last air heat and sends her
flying into the wall but this gives judy
just enough time to grab a nearby cross
something she probably should have done
a while ago and press it to malthus's
head
mary ellen places the annabelle doll
back into the chapel glass case but
malthus power prevents her from being
able to force its shots things look
hopeless as all of the escaped evil
spirits from that night surround them
but luckily for them
daniela shows up now free of the demonic
possession she is the only character
that we know of to ever be freed from
malthus's grit and with her strength
they're able to force annabelle's case
closed
i can only imagine that daniela never
actually gave in to the idea of malthus
taking her soul and that's why she was
able to be exercised the doll and the
demonic presence bound to it are once
again sealed and without the spiritual
beacon of the annabelle toll malthus and
the other spirits are no longer able to
materialize in our world
the evil has been contained as far as we
know malthus would remain locked in edin
lorraine warren's cursed artifact room
from that point forward but the real
life story
is perhaps open to another chapter
lorraine warren passed away in april of
2019
and left the cursed artifact room which
is known in real life as the warrens
occult museum to her son-in-law tony
spira that's judy's husband
in 2020 because of course this would
happen in 2020 it was reported that the
annabelle doll had somehow escaped and
was now missing from the room
tony sparrow took to youtube to shoot
down these rumors annabelle's here
she didn't go anywhere she didn't take a
trip
so you know here she is so let's put the
rumors to rest guys
but during this fiasco it also came out
that tony and judy were looking to
relocate the museum which had been
closed for some time due to zoning
issues so it's not hard to imagine a
future controvers story where one of the
movers doesn't take the proper
precautions with the annabelle doll and
malthus is set loose
once more we've seen a lot of these many
years later horror sequels recently so
maybe a modern day annabelle sequel
could eventually be
in the cards let me know in the comments
which other controvers characters or
entities you'd like to see covered here
on horror history and if you love horror
remember to subscribe to cz's world for
new horrors every week
ring the death bell not the spirit bell
for notifications and i will
see you in the next one assuming we both
survive
[Music]